Please pass to paradise. You're here
with us. You choose your path.
I am here with you.
You choose your path with the god of
paradise.
God bless your soul. Your ally. Bless
your soul.
>> He was between the both of us.
Alamikum guys. Before the video starts,
brothers and sisters, one Umar is
working in Pakistan with the floods
that's hit the country. 1,700 people
have lost their life. Millions of people
have lost their homes and been
displayed. So the videos that you can
see here, the pictures that you can see,
guys, is demonstrating what onem is
doing on the ground. We know Gaza is
important and we know what's going on
there. But brothers and sisters, we
cannot enable and turn a blind eye to
the suffering of Muslims in different
countries. Be it Pakistan, be it Turkey,
the earthquakes, wherever it may be,
Afghanistan, so many other places need
our help. And I know all of us have
given as much as we can to Gaza. But
brothers and sisters, wahi, just imagine
your home wrecked. Thousands of people
have died. Your family members have
passed away. You have nowhere to live.
Brothers and sisters, they need our help
as much as Gaza does. So I urge you
guys, inshallah, it's 100% donation
policy. Donate whatever amount, even if
it's one pound. The prophet peace be
upon him said, "The best form of sodak
is to give water." Brothers and sisters,
let's give them food and shelter and
water to drink so they can overcome this
tragedy. Inshallah, I urge you guys to
go to the link and donate now. Enjoy the
video. Lucy, how you doing, Lucy? Are
you coming back from work or where you
been?
>> Uh, just kind of guessing in life. Just
>> you're guessing in life, sister, have
you ever wondered what's the purpose of
life? Why am I here? Where am I going?
>> Uh, not so much me, but other people
I've had that thought about.
>> But do you ever think to yourself like
the way you're created? You know,
there's some unique things about
yourself. your fingerprint, for example,
your DNA.
>> Yes. Um, and they even said your teeth.
No one's teeth is the same as others.
>> Our teeth structure.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's like a unique ID. Like my
fingerprint doesn't match your
fingerprint. My DNA is completely
separate to yours. So, the question is
the following. It's impossible that a
randomness can give course rise to this.
There has to be a law maker cuz there's
order. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? So, do you believe in a higher
being?
>> Yeah, I do. Okay. So, we believe we're
Muslims. We believe that God is one. We
call him Allah. It means the true God.
So, we say the following, sister. This
being that you believe in, do you
believe it's energy or do you believe
it's a personal being?
>> I don't know right now. I'm kind of
willing to learn.
>> Okay. Perfect. Let me give you an
example. Behind us, we have like it's a
picture, but imagine that was a
painting.
>> Let's suppose that was a painting. Yeah.
>> By looking at that painting, we know a
lot about the painter. For example,
number one, that he exists. So if if
this was a painting, we would know that
somebody painted it.
>> Number two, we would know that they
wanted to paint. They had the will to
paint. Number three, we would say that
they had knowledge cuz without
knowledge, you can't do anything.
>> And also they had to have some kind of
power to paint to do the painting. Yeah.
So now when I look at you or when you
look at me, you would understand that we
are some kind of like a painting. We're
a design. So then the question comes to
the the following. If a being exists,
then he has to have attributes. Meaning
he willed to create her. So he must have
a will. He must be the all knowing. Why?
Because you are made out of DNA. DNA has
information in it. Do you know that?
>> Of course.
>> Yeah. Okay. So information requires
intelligence. So that means that being
has to be the all knowing. He has to be
the all powerful. For example, today you
ate.
>> Yes.
>> You went you were sleeping.
>> Your heart beats.
>> So we say that he has to be the
sustainer because if he's created us,
he's the one that makes our heartbeat.
He's the one that provides us
nourishment. The fact that my stomach
can take the food I eat and give me
nutrition.
>> Okay. I I understand what you're saying.
I understand and I believe in what
you're saying, but I hope that this
whatever you're filming me for.
>> Yeah. Oh, we're live on YouTube. Sorry,
forgive me. Yeah.
>> I hope that this is tempered with my own
vision whereby I believe in what you're
doing is beautiful and I think it's
wonderful.
>> Thank you.
>> But I have my own vision of God. Sure.
Why is that? Do you mind sharing it with
us?
>> It's my own personal personal. Okay.
>> It's a personal God. It's
>> okay. That's good.
>> I don't wake up every morning and like
pray to God.
>> I know that life is going to be okay.
And I've been through a rough ride in
life. Um but I hope that this isn't
going to be kind of put out as like not
we're just having a nice discussion just
>> I do believe in certain excerpts of the
Quran. I do believe in the Quran but I
also believe in other things like
Buddhism. I believe in
spiritual spiritualism. I believe in
other parts of
>> humanity and I think that that is part
of humanity is
>> of course of course I mean we're here
like for us you know sharing this
information with you is just to you know
get to understand each other better. So
to us like we said we don't believe God
is a man or a woman. We believe he's one
being. He's not in the creation. He's
not a man or a woman. He's not a statue.
We believe he's all powerful because
he's created billions of species. So
what we say is that argument sake, if I
give you an example, if I said to you,
I'll give you 10 billion pounds, but
you're going to die tomorrow. Would you
take it?
>> You can give me every kind of gold like
question or 10 billion pounds, but I
live this I live on this earth
>> in complete peace.
>> That's good.
>> And I walk day in and day out. And I
wake up and I'm thankful for my life.
>> That's good. Gratitude is very important
as well. Yeah, that's good. That's a
very good point.
>> And I pray to a higher power.
>> Wow. Okay.
>> And now that higher power may be for
you, Allah.
>> Yeah.
>> Or for somebody else, Buddha, or maybe
for somebody else, Christ. I don't know.
>> But for me, it's somebody I don't know.
But I'm finding out right now. Okay,
that's good.
>> And I'm okay with that.
>> Okay, that's good. Is there anything you
would like to know about why we worship
Allah or is it like just if you have any
questions I would like to share that
with you or or or are you happy where
you are? Would you like to be a bit like
you know I want to know about Islam and
what is going on?
>> I am
>> I am completely peaceful in my life.
>> Okay, fantastic. I'm I'm very happy to
hear that. It's good to know that you
are peaceful and I hope God increases
you in peace. Uh to us we believe that
the closer we and I think it's your you
have a relationship with God Almighty.
The closer you get to him, the peace
will grow and I'm happy for you.
>> Thank you. And I I feel that we're on
the same
>> 100%. Yeah, definitely.
>> And I wish you well, my brother.
>> Thank you very much. Can I Sister,
what's your name?
>> Lucy.
>> Sorry. Just out of respect, we don't
shake hands with opposite gender.
>> That's okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Just out of respect or
nothing in the in the air without
touching. Yeah. There we go. You know
why? Because we believe every woman is
like a queen, you know, and we believe,
for example, that that's our way of
respect. Cuz you know, in today's time,
for example, sometimes you're in the
workplace, you have male colleagues
might touch your shoulder and you want
to know what's appropriate. And
sometimes some people are uncomfortable.
So to us, what we do is we rather
there's no physical touch cuz that might
some people might be comfortable
touching the shoulder head with us. It's
just out of respect. No 100%. Cuz we
appreciate every woman has value to
offer. We are against the western
society's sexualization objectification
of women. We're really against that, you
know, because it dehumanizes them. You
know, a woman has so much more to offer.
Why is she in front of a chocolate bar
or a car, you know? So we just say that
as a Muslim from our religion, God
teaches us Muslim men to lower our gaze.
Meaning do not look at a woman in that
manner. That's why we have utmost
respect to the opposite gender. And vice
versa like my wife can't shake the hand
of the opposite. Uh it's not it's not a
uh just a Muslim man thing. A Muslim
woman is not allowed to shake the hand
of a man as well. Be the Muslim. Like if
a Muslim woman in a hijab want to shake
my hand, I'll say sorry. No. So just so
you know, it's not. Cuz some people
think it's a non-Muslim thing. It's not.
Yeah. Exactly. I'm very curious though
as your uh sorry Muslim wife.
>> Yes.
>> If she like how long have you been
together?
>> Uh we've been together about 6 years.
>> 6 years. So
>> when you reach a certain point like
clearly you've met each other and you
have a very lovely relationship etc. At
some point
there will be erosion. There's going to
be moments where she will seek
>> uh I don't know. Um
>> I'll be honest. Yeah, it's fine.
>> I
>> She may seek somebody somebody else like
>> Okay.
>> And that's a normal reaction from um a
sense of
um I don't know.
>> So do do you mean like for example if
she comes to a point where she's not
happy with me
>> or she wants to be with someone else?
Okay. Well, in Islam if that's the case,
it's very simple. She has a right to
divorce. She can say for example um I do
not want
>> she very simple like in Islam there is
no force like for example in
Christianity you cannot get divorced in
Judaism if the man doesn't give you the
divorce you're married to him for
eternity in Islam Islam gave the right
to a woman to divorce 1400 years ago
meaning if she's not and by the way some
people don't know this if a woman is
sexually not satisfied in the bedroom in
as a Muslim woman she has every right to
say I would not like to be with you
Islam gives her full right for divorce
>> so why is sorry like lots of questions.
>> How do I please?
>> So, okay, that's on one part, but also
uh certain Muslim men get three
>> four wives.
>> Okay, why is that?
>> Okay, so what Islam does is Islam is
pragmatic. So, for example, let's take
ourel a bit. There's reasons. So, let's
go a bit couple of hundred years ago. We
didn't have Tesco around the corner. It
was a like tribal like u living style in
the sense where you need to understand.
For example, if I have four wives, I
could impregnate all four of them. They
know who the father is. they know who
the mother is. So before we add all DNA
and who the father is number one. So
number one for lineage. Number two for
example for survival because you need to
understand you got different tribes
there's wars happening. So in order to
increase your population that is one
reason. Number two usually men die in
wars. Like for example world war II
there was an instance I don't know if it
was in the UK or France so many men died
that they would encourage men to get
married. So so did you get that's number
two. Number three, for example, um there
is um many other reasons like for
example, even if we look at today's
time, there's far more men who are
homosexuals. So, which means there are
more women that are single and can't
find a partner. So, what Islam says is
the following. If it's going to be done,
it has to be done in the right way. Now,
let me give you the reason that applies
to today. How many men do you know who
have side chicks, mistresses, and
girlfriends who cheat on their wives?
So, what Islam says is the following,
sister. If you are going to do it, you
have to do it in a correct way without
degrading this other woman. So what men
usually do is the following. They say,
"Okay, I have a wife, but I have the
innate desire to be with another woman."
Okay, what they do is they mistreat that
other woman by argument say she's just a
side chick. Islam says, "No, it doesn't
work like that. If you are going to do
it, you are going to do it the proper
way." How you married your first wife,
you have to marry her. You gave her
dowy. You know what a dowry is?
>> Dary. Yeah.
>> You have to give the diary to the second
wife. You buy her a car, you buy her a
car. You buy her a phone, you buy her a
phone. What that does is it says
equality to a certain degree. So what
the man does is he's thinking, okay, I
just want to be with the second wife
just for sex. So Islam says, uh-uh, you
can't do that because you have to meet
the father. So he's thinking, oh my
gosh, I have to go through all of these
obstacles. It deters a man to do it the
right way. So So what what we do is in
today's time, there's so many men. In
France is to have a mistress is it's
fashion. It's like casual thing. So what
Islam says is no, you are not allowed to
degrade another woman and use an abuser.
If it's going to be done, let it be done
the right way.
>> Very that place my mind. Okay.
>> Yeah. Obviously as a female like even
for my wife, it's something that it's
it's not easy because sharing your man.
But what Islam does, Islam deals with
the pragmatic reality of life.
>> You can imagine as like a western woman
though to date like a man like yourself.
Can you imagine how hard that is? And
like to understand that particularly on
dating apps.
>> Yes. Like do you mean do you mean like
if somebody wanted to marry me? Is that
what you mean? Like
>> No. No. Like as in can you imagine your
your belief system?
>> Okay. Yes.
>> And so
>> Yes.
>> And we have to Sorry. I I'm here as like
a westernized sorry I'm open to all
sorts. To be honest with I I am here
>> to accept everybody. My my daughter is
mixed race.
>> Oh wow. Okay. Yes.
>> Um
>> but to to be open to people we don't
know this. So
>> how
>> so so do you mean it's hard to grasp the
idea this specific thing?
>> Yeah. I don't think we're given enough
knowledge of it.
>> It's not. But what it is is if you think
about it sister polygamy or polygyny is
something that is practiced by
non-Muslim men. So there are so many men
who do not follow Islam that do polygyny
but they do it the wrong way. What Islam
does is it says look here's protocols to
do it the right way because otherwise
what do men do? They go have one night
stats sleep around have children.
>> Do you get what I'm trying to say? So
what Islam does? Islam has come to
protect the communal right. So it says
hold on a sec. You can't go and sleep
around have children abandon them. No
you have to take care of them. You have
to marry her. So what Islam does is take
men to account via polygyny by saying if
it's going to be done here's the
protocols and it should be done the
right way. But so many men do it the
wrong way.
But is it is it men that are the
problem?
>> It's not a must. No, no, no. It's not a
must. Look, it's not
>> No, but is it men though? Is it men?
Like, are you the problem? Are you
>> I want to say like every every like I'm
sorry to like let's call a spade a
spade. Yeah.
>> Like
>> I live my life in peace. Yeah.
>> Like every now and then I'd like Sorry
to sound blunt. Every now and then I'd
like to have a shag. Yeah. Every now and
then have a shag. every intimacy
intimacy
>> with your partner or you talking about
some
>> just in general I'm single I I live my
you know I live my life single because
I' I've I have raised my child I've
dealt with lots of problematic men but
I'm sorry I've decided to live my life
single and free because
>> men are just right now a bit too much
for me
>> and I don't blame you and this is the
reason why it's so important to follow a
way of life. You know why sister? You've
come across all of these deadbeat men
who have come and given you maybe for I
don't know the reality. The false
promises may have broken your heart and
come into your life and left you. This
is why it is so important and pertinent
for a man as a Muslim man. I cannot
date. All I do is it's a serious thing
for me. It's marriage or not marriage.
Which means the following. Islam
protects your heart because you have had
experience with these men who have
broken you that you cannot even trust
them. Listen, can I tell you right now
I'm going so I'm I am leaving for the
UK. I I I am traveling to meet
>> business partners in Dubai, Abu Dhabi
and mah. I believe in what you're
saying. I believe in everything. I like
the mah
>> my mother my mother
>> looks after some of the most like
amazing families in Saudi Arabia
>> but
>> I don't think we can compare them to the
men of what I'm talking about but
what I'm saying is these men the reason
excuse my language I'll call them crap
instead of that word the reason why
these men are like that is because
society you see when the core Islam
deals with the core Islam kills men to
be real men from Allah tells me in the
Quran tell the believing men to lower
his gaze meaning number one do not
sexually objectify women in today's time
these men watch pornography women are
sexually objectified so what it does is
they dehumanize women to a state that
when they are with you you don't even
know their true intentions that's the
reason why Islam has given a protocol
argument say if when I met my wife I had
to speak to her father why because a man
knows a man
>> respect God I respect you for that
>> but but do you know why sister you know
why Because number one, I fear God.
Number two, I'm not here to play around.
My wife, I had to there there was a like
when I was getting to know her, there
was a chaperon, somebody there. Why?
Because Islam gives heavy emphasis on
the protection of one's heart. So
protect her and protect me. Cuz imagine
what happens in today's society. Have
casual sex, casual dating. Do you know
what's doing to your soul? You are
giving your trust of your body, your
heart to a man's hand or a woman's hand.
Cuz there's some women there as well.
And they're crushing and giving it back
to you. Crushing and giving it back to
you. So Islam is saying no. No dating
before um marriage. If you are serious,
number one, you speak to the father.
Number two, there's going to be a
chaperone dating so you don't take
advantage of her. Number three, if you
decide to marry her, you need to give
her a dowy. Like for example, when I
married my wife, I I provide for
everything because Islam says yes.
Exactly. So what that does is it
protects my wife's heart. Not not she
doesn't need to think about, oh, is he
messing around? Which girl? My wife, I
have no female friends. I'm not allowed
to have female friends. And my wife, I
give access to my phone. You know why
>> you should be allowed? No, but that's
the whole thing. You should be allowed
to have female friends.
>> Let me tell you why. Because men and
women cannot be friends. There's studies
that show this. You know why? The reason
why
>> that's where me and you disagree.
>> Okay. But let's talk about studies.
Studies say, sister, a man and a woman,
they are created in a way to have
attraction.
>> Are you driven by studies?
>> Okay. I'm driven by my religion. I'm
just saying studies support that in
Islam.
>> You know what? Can I give you a really
honest opinion from a really honest
woman? Yeah. I've been single for seven
years. Yeah. I I literally
>> went through hell
>> and I met some really nice men along the
way and we we you know what also in the
same breath
>> because I wanted to date so I put myself
on dating apps so I put myself and those
apps were hell
>> yes they are
>> they are awful they are God's worst work
>> yes
>> and I put myself on them to try and meet
somebody I took myself off them there's
a one guy I met and he was a very kind
man, very kind man. And we speak and he
said I said I don't like you as anything
more. He said Lucy I will be your dear
friend.
>> Okay.
>> And that is all I ask of you. We've
remained good friends.
>> Okay. That's a I would say that's an
anomaly that can happen. I will never
say it can't happen. With Islam we deal
with prevention is better than cure
because men and women have that
attraction to one another. It's to
protect myself and protect cuz you know
why everyone has a propensity to cheat.
is if you put yourself in certain
environments. Do you get it? Now you
might call that a friend sister for
argument sake one day he drops you home
you have a drink something. So what
Islam is says look let's deal with the
evil by preventing it rather than doing
it and then going looking for a cure. So
to me I have no female friends. Number
one cuz my religion is it and number two
my wife wouldn't appreciate it and I
don't have like I don't even have to
shake the hands of opposite gender and
even when I'm speaking to them if you
notice I call them sister. Why? Because
I don't want them to have that idea that
I'm trying to you know maybe ch them or
something. So to me why because I value
my wife I value my religion I value the
one that I has created me. So these
things are there in places that you know
why because society says what have
friends have a casual drink have this
but they all lead to atrocities in the
sense where you're destroying your soul.
You shouldn't be having this experience
with these men who have treated you in
this manner.
>> Of course you get it. But I also think I
also think that you you are allowed as a
human being
>> against your religion to have a
relationship with men or women and you
should walk free on this earth.
>> Okay?
>> And you should you you should you know
I'd like to walk into my friend's house
who's a man
>> or a woman and eat bread and
>> Okay. Good. But you know what is sister?
I'm a man. I know how men can think a
lot of the time. So are you but you're
judging your own
>> I know myself mind.
>> Yes I know myself. You know why?
>> But is that so is that the Quran's mind?
>> No no no no. That's me as a man how God
has created me. Like for example let me
put it like this. For example you're
you're a woman and you know how woman
could be. Correct.
>> You're you're a female. So for examp
imagine you have a husband and your
husband says there's this work colleague
at work. Yeah. As a woman. So imagine
you see them a little bit close. They're
friend. She says, "I'm a friend." As a
woman, would you not think, "Hold on a
second. I know how some woman could want
to grab another man from his family." So
you would put yourself in that woman's
shoes and say, "I have the propensity to
do that. Not that I would, she may do."
So what Islam does, Islam says, listen
those things can happen. It's better
that there is no friendship. Now for
example, look, I'm talking to you.
However, I have no female friends which
are talking. I have no need to talk to
them in no way, shape, or form. And let
me tell you why. For example, casino. Do
you believe casino is a good place or a
bad place?
>> Don't really give a
>> Well, it destroys people's lives. Well,
it destroys people's lives.
>> No, I mean like I'd go there for a joke
on one.
>> Exactly. But you know some jokes like
going there. There's one man that I was
watching a documentary. He was about to
take his life cuz he lost hundreds of
thousands of pounds just by one stone.
There are people who have become
alcoholics with one cup.
>> Of course. Look at the trauma though,
don't you?
>> True sister. But what I'm saying is
Islam says if that one cup is going to
make you a drunkard, don't do it. If one
slot machine is going to turn you into a
gambling addict and you're going to
spend your children's money on gambling,
don't do it. If that friend that you're
going to have is going to cause you to
commit adultery, it's better not to do
it. And if you had you have child
children, right?
>> One child.
>> Okay. Imagine your child says, "I want
to try cocaine."
>> Do you see that reaction? Because you
care about them. And guess what God's
reaction is for you? Because God cares
about you. things that are going to ruin
you. He says no. Just the way your child
will say, "But mom, I want to be free.
Let me just try cocaine." You will say,
"No, it will ruin your life." The same
thing with God. God cares about you more
than your own mother. So, he's saying
these things don't do it.
>> Thank you. Can I can I tell you thank
you? Because tonight my my partner dies.
Uh he died two weeks ago. Tomorrow is
his funeral.
>> Sorry. Is this your ex-husband?
>> Uh he's my ex partner. He's 45.
>> Yeah. and his funeral is tomorrow at 12.
So
>> I hope you can pray for him because I
pray for him because his body he's not a
he's not a rested soul.
>> So whatever religion you believe in I
hope that we can as rel as a Christian
>> as a Muslim I hope that we like maybe we
can say a prayer.
>> Yeah. I mean I'm sorry to hear like I
just we hope like we believe that God is
the most just and God will never punish
a soul unjustly and we believe God will
never ever if he was a man who didn't
hear about Islam we even believe he has
a chance of entering paradise so we
believe God is the most
>> maybe ask him Raymond Joe
please pass to paradise you're here with
us you choose your path
I am here with
[Music]
You choose your path with the god of
paradise.
>> God bless your soul, your ally. Bless
your soul.
>> He was between the both of us.
>> Yeah. I'm really sorry to hear for you.
>> That's okay.
>> It was lovely talking to you. We're here
every Friday and Sunday. Deep message.
>> It was. It was. It was. And and things
don't happen for no reason. Have you
read the Quran before?
>> Um, no. But I would
>> Can I give you a free copy?
>> Can I read that?
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. It's a free copy for you.
And I'll give you one more gift. If you
ever feel like there's no way out. This
is a prayer mat. It teaches you how to
pray. Put in front and maybe one day it
might be useful to you. It has like a It
shows how we Muslims pray. So I know you
say you're a Buddhist etc. You're
spiritual. Maybe you can Ali.
>> Ali.
>> Yes. Yes. Nice me sister. If you
remember the the the
tip. Sorry.
>> Yes. It's been really hard for me these
past couple of days.
>> I'm so sorry to that. And that's why
maybe God sent you here for a reason.
>> Yeah. And I really feel it.
>> Yes.
>> Thank you, sister. We're here every
Friday and Sunday if you want to come
and talk more. If you're going through
anything, we're here for you. Um Yeah.
And yes, we ask Allah to inshallah guide
you to the right path.
>> I'm off to uh Abu Dhabi and uh
>> Oh, fantastic. And Saudi Oh, wow. And
>> when is that?
>> Uh September. I've got three of the
continents I'm going to.
>> You know what? There's a reason God is
sending you to the Islamic lands
>> and suddenly I feel this.
>> That's good. We we we will pray for you.
May Allah subhanaa tala guide you in
sister. Thank you, sister. Inshallah.
>> Inshah. In